you know you can tell George is an old
friend of mine when he can sort of pimp
me about on time
look I when I heard about this when
George asked me to come
someone had described this as a lecture
and you know I think of lectures as
something that smart people do and they
impart learning right so this can't
possibly be a lecture it'll be a talk
and the reason for that is I'm in the
airline business I'm an airline
executive so by definition I'm not smart
all right and secondly I'm in a business
that hasn't earned an adequate return on
its invested capital since the Wright
brothers so I'm a slow learner as well
all right so what I'll talk to you about
is I'll talk to you a little bit about
the airline business and then I'll do a
small while I'm doing this I'll do a
small commercial for the new United
Airlines because I want all of you to
fly us and I want you to pay always
booked at the last minute pay the
highest fare that's the key and then
I'll talk a little bit a little bit
about about leadership as well let me
start by talking about the airline
business it is an extraordinary business
and I like to say and your and most of
you are getting your MBAs your PhDs
you know if you like the business of
business there is no business like the
airline business if you like making
money forget it it's a tough tough
business and it's a tough business
because of a lot of structural problems
with the business it has very low
barriers to entry I like to say any
idiot can get an operating certificate
and many do it has very high barriers to
exit because everybody who touches us
makes money off of us whether it's the
airframe manufacturers of the engine
manufacturers the aircraft lessors the
cities where we operate whether it's
it's the avionics manufacturers the
folks who service the laboratories you
name it they make money on us and as a
result nobody wants us to die and that's
why you see so many airlines that go
into bankruptcy and yet they get
reconstituting they come out they don't
liquidate they come out the other end
and so you have you have basically an
open opportunity for a new entrance
and a cap on exit and therefore you tend
to have an overcapacity which tends to
drive down fares which tends to make us
unprofitable we're also a brutally
regulated business recognizing that the
airlines were deregulated in 1978 only
nominally we are the most heavily
regulated deregulated business that
there is and some of the regulations
make a lot of sense I mean certainly the
safety regulations make enormous sense
but sometimes industrial organization is
mixed in with safety and consumer
protection is mixed in in regulations in
ways that that are that are fairly
oppressive for example you probably know
that the air traffic control system in
the United States is quite antiquated
it's safe don't get me wrong it's safe
but it's just very very slow and it uses
the very finest 1950s ground-based radar
technology that money could buy and we
need to invest in that system but what
we haven't as a nation and as a result
it's it's a the system has very limited
throughput and particularly in times of
bad weather that's why you have all of
these all the many many delays and in
bad weather days but if as a result of
our antiquated air traffic control
system our airplanes are stuck on a
taxiway for more than three hours we get
fined twenty seven thousand five hundred
dollars per passenger per passenger now
I'm gonna give you a Lulu we don't
charge that much per passenger alright
and and and so as a result we have lots
of regulations they're very oppressive
on the air care someone actually
recently said well why don't you charge
for air tickets because fuel is so
important to you why don't you sell an
air ticket and then at the last minute
whatever the fuel price is that you're
gonna be using that'll be the cost and
the customers credit card would be
charged that I mean it'll be a logical
thing to do well the federal government
about a week ago outlawed that practice
before we could even start that practice
even if any of us were so we're very
heavily regulated in the ways that we
advertise the way that we operate the
ways we price our tickets even though
nominally we're a deregulated business
and we're also subject to to external
events that most businesses are not I
mean last year last April there was a
volcanic eruption the name of which I've
never been able to name that
volcano maybe one of you can do it but
it really shut down air travel in Europe
and and was it had a fairly material
adverse effect on air travel who could
have thought when you were planning for
the year that you would be subject to a
volcano or subject to SARS or subject
any of a number of of these external
events that affect our industry and
certainly the price of fuel is you know
is remarkably difficult for us to handle
because not only is it an important
input for us in fact it's our single
highest cost we spend more on fuel than
we do on our people worldwide or our
aircraft worldwide our facilities were a
lie or anything worldwide and when we
when when fuel is such an important
input price and it's quite high and
quite volatile to give you a concept of
how much I mean George mentioned twenty
five thousand dollars a minute which is
a lot of money which is why I try to
talk really really fast right but if you
think about what it is at the United
Airlines the new United combined
continent and and the United Airlines we
for what we spend on fuel we could buy a
brand new Airbus a380 aircraft you know
what that is that really big aircraft
that spins a little regional jets around
like tops you'd be probably seeing that
we could buy a brand new Airbus a380 a
week and throw it away for the price of
what we spend on fuel and so when you've
got that size of an input price over
which you have no control now you can do
hedging and we do hedge we do typical
had you using typical financial products
to hedge but the reality is ultimately
those hedges burn off and you have to
pay the higher price of fuel and you've
got to figure out a way to recover that
higher cost and this time around this
bump in fuel in 2011 were as an industry
doing a better job we were in 2008 and
2008
you know a lot of airlines got in a lot
of trouble with high very high fuel
prices and a high in fuel prices peaked
at 172 dollars a barrel for jet fuel
we're paying today about a hundred and
thirty six dollars a barrel for jet fuel
so it's pretty close to what it had been
at its peak well we've done a much
better job of pricing to it we've had a
number of fare increases this year and
we're also doing a better job as you
obviously as you price your product
higher you're going to have less demand
and we've got a good job adjusting our
capacity so we don't have too many seeds
chasing too few butts but in terms of
capital cost huge capital costs very
sophisticated financing which we do for
all the capital we do technology we have
we're essentially a technology company
with wings it's a very data rich
business a very data rich business and
as a result we have a lot of information
on which to make a decision but we also
have a lot of data you've got to figure
out how to parse your way through that
data and I'm sure many of you have been
faced with a whole lot of data and
trying to figure out what seeing through
this this this this fog of data what
actually is very important to you so
what's it's without question a difficult
business and as George mentioned it's
also heavily unionized business and that
imparts its own set of difficulties and
certainly in a merger like we're doing
we did the merger because we were this
is a network business and having the the
largest single network in the world is
very valuable and also there are lots of
other assets you get an a merger of the
size that we've done for example our
loyalty program our frequent flyer
program has more members than there are
citizens of France worldwide and and
that that imparts a lot of value knowing
and the loyalty of the customers but
also in our ability to to sell miles to
third parties like chase the credit
cards things like that it's really
valuable but bringing together bringing
together carriers has its own issues and
certainly the workgroups are a very
difficult issue we have work groups that
are represented by the same Union we
have work groups that are represented by
different unions we have work groups
some of whom are not unionized at the
Continental side are unionized on the
United side and you've got to bring
those together and that's a that's a
that's a long process but an important
process and you've got to you've got to
earn
to earn the people's trust over time I
think the most difficult thing in in
bringing two carriers together of the
size of continental United it really is
cultural because we are very two
different carriers with two different
cultures and and professor Parker is is
well you know well-versed in in the old
continental culture but that's really
important in the service business and I
want to talk a little bit a little bit
about that as I talk more on the sort of
the the leadership aspect of this you
know if you're if you're trying to get
together 87,000 diverse people as we are
in this in this merged Enterprise you've
got to have a vision for them and that's
what I'm paid to do is CEO but
importantly you've got to have a plan
that they understand and if you if you
know if you don't know where you're
going any road will take you there right
so you've got to have a plan in it and
and and at the new combined carrier
we're using a plan that we have used on
the Continental side for 16 years it's a
simple one-page plan that is everything
we want to do is on a single piece of
paper or a single I I've had pages the
case may be and it's important that
people understand that plan it's
important that you that that everybody
understands it and it's most important
that you tell people that if what
they're working on if they can't trace
it back to that plan then they should
stop what they're doing and do something
else because you can you can distill
everything you want in a business into a
marketing plan and into a financial plan
and into an operating plan and into a
people plan and what we do at the
combined carrier is we just take the
most important things that we're going
to be doing for the year and we put them
under each column for the marketing plan
and for the financial planner for the
operating plan for the people planning
to list it out and we make sure people
understand what they're working on and
why they're working on it and it's
really important to show that and get
that out and around the system so that
people know where you're going because
people want to believe in a future but
you've got to show them what the future
is going to be but then you have to show
them how
to get to that place and so having a key
a simple clear plan is incredibly
valuable for leading change bringing
businesses together leading your troops
and going over it over and over and it
can get repetitive I understand that but
it's important that everybody understand
how they fit in because you know from
from the perspective of the you know
person on the ramp throwing bags they
wonder what what part are they how are
they participating in the carrier what
are they doing how are they contributing
to the future and they can do that by
understanding what we're doing in the
plan the other the second thing I'd want
to make sure you understand for your own
leadership positions going forward from
from what I've learned is the incredible
importance of getting really talented
people to work with you and work for you
as you become leaders yourself there are
people who are insecure and they won't
hire really good people because they
want to be better than the people are
reporting to them they want to know more
my theory has always been you got you
find the very best people that you can
find and you hire them and you actually
try to hire people who are better at
your own job than you'll ever be and
then leave them alone I mean a lot of
people micromanage and there's nothing
more dispiriting to people who work for
you than to micromanage them if you if
you've hired the right people and you've
given them the tools that they need to
do their job effectively then you want
to trust them and you want to let them
make some mistakes now I don't mean
mistakes like I mistakenly took some of
the company's cash and put it in my bank
account
not that kind of mistake but let them
let let them run with it and don't
micromanagement you know what you'll
find is 99 times out of 100 they'll do
the right thing they'll be really good
and the one time out of a hundred you
may have to sit down and give them a
little counseling but it's really
important to hire the very very best
people and then make sure they've got
the tools to do the job and then let
them run with it because if you're
constantly you know if you're constantly
in their underwear I'll tell you it
makes their lives miserable and you'll
drive good people off whereas if you
give them lots of responsible and let
them run with it now it's important that
you not get sandbagged I mean what I
tell my own direct reports is you go run
with the business and you go do what's
right but keep me informed I don't ever
want to discover something material you
know at a board
it'd be nice for you to tell me in
advance so make sure you don't sandbag
me but it's important to get those
people and let them run now that's not
to say as leaders that you can't get
intimately involved in portions of the
business and I would encourage you to do
that as well I mean I reserve the right
of CEO to go do kind of you know put my
nose in whatever I want to from a
business perspective but it's and it's
important to know that because there are
leaders who are at you know forty
thousand feet all the time there's sort
of the what I would call the Business
Roundtable leaders you know the talking
heads on TV the people who make broad
generic statements but don't actually
know what's going on in their business
and you can get isolated really quickly
as you rise up to the ranks now I've got
for example I've got eight sided card
security identification display area of
cards those are the things you use to go
airside and I had to go by the way watch
eight separate spot the terrorist videos
to get this thing which is really an
unpleasant experience to have to go
through to get these badges but I will
tell you it's really valid because I can
go airside I can go and just walk in in
any break room and I do that alone
without an entourage and it's really
valuable cuz you get to know people over
time and make sure you're also mixing
with the folks you're working with I
mean on every airplane I go up in the
flight deck before the airplane takes
off I talk to the pilots the reason I do
that before the airplane takes off is if
I do it in flight they lock the door and
they won't let me out and they have lots
and lots of questions I like to answer
the questions but there's a limit to
what I can do right and and again I and
then I work all the galleys and I talked
to all the flight attendants and then go
into break room so over the years at
Continental I know thousands and
thousands and thousands of people and
that's really valuable as a manager
because that way the people who report
you can't [ __ ] you I mean they can
tell you things but you can go one or
two or three levels deep and get the
real information and the fact is the
people who now now work for me know I
can do that so they don't [ __ ] me
because they know I can I can dig in the
organization and that's that's that's
really valuable but I think the most
important thing that you can that you
can bring as leaders in the future to
your own enterprises whether they're are
the for-profit or nonprofit is is the
culture of the business I'm a huge
believer that culture matters in a
business now I'm in a service business
where it's sort of you know obviously
culture is important and we have
different cultures at these two Airlines
I'm trying to bring together a culture
and it's even more difficult because
because this particular transaction that
we did the United continent was a merger
of equals where we didn't acquire we at
Continental didn't acquire United United
and acquire common you know we're trying
to bring together the best of both but
we're trying to bring together the best
of both cultures and and and you know I
sort of I've always lived my life by two
rules that my sort of mommy taught me
which which is treat other people like
you'd like to be treated and never tell
a lie it's really simple and you can be
successful doing that and at the airline
sort of treating each other like you'd
like to be treated is what we call
dignity and respect treating each other
and treating our customers with dignity
and respect that means being honest with
people that means that means thanking
people I'll tell you many people again
as you progress in your careers you have
folks who are working for you you know
you you you you thank people with it
with financial incentives and you
structure them appropriately and that's
why we're all in business because you
know you do you do want to get paid in
business but even more importantly often
than the financial incentives even more
important that are the the personal
thank yous I mean and I don't mean that
I don't mean superficial I mean having
people who've done a really good job and
go taking the trouble to go to their
office or go to their cube and thank
them personally I mean it makes a huge
difference to them and I would encourage
you as well to always remember that
there's so many people who work really
hard work all through the night to make
you look good and you need to make sure
you're thanking those folks as you go
through your career and build up those
relationships because it's incredibly
important but treating your co-workers
with respect treating your customers
with respect is incredibly important and
also being open direct and open and
honest it's always better to tell the
truth if you make a mistake got up to it
quickly it can be fixed there's some
mistakes can be fixed most mistakes can
be fixed but being open AUSA in my
business that means not only being
direct and open honest with my
co-workers but also with customers so if
there's a problem as a delay say what
the delay is tell people why there's
delay if you don't know why the
aircraft's delay
say I don't know but I'll figure it out
and explain what's going on people
people much prefer that than did silence
or the runaround that also means when I
go out and talk to co-workers I do I do
CEO exchanges something similar to this
actually where I speak for a few minutes
and then I open up for a half-hour
questions of my co-workers and they've
learned over the years on the content
side and the united folks are learning
they can get up on a microphone that can
ask me any question they want and I'll
give them a direct and open and honest
answer now sometimes that means tell
them something they don't want to hear I
don't always agree with them but it's
not when someone comes up to you with an
idea that you know you'll never do it's
not patting them on the shoulder and
saying you know great idea I'll consider
it it's saying no we won't do that and
here's the reason why or when someone
stands up and and makes it a you know a
group of folks in the unit step and make
a demand for a contract that you know
will not be in knowing the long-run
interest or interest of the company
harmful to the rest of the coworkers
explain that you'll never do that and
use the word never it's a tough word but
it's true word that is you'll never do a
contract that will jeopardize the future
of the company or jeopardize the future
of the co-workers now people sometimes
don't want to hear the tough message but
it's important to give that tough mess
you can give it politely and you can
politely and you can do it respectfully
but it's important because when you do
that when you've got when you've got a
culture that's built around people
treating each other with dignity and
respect and direct and open and honest
communication what you build is a
company where people enjoy coming to
work every day they trust each other
and they learn and and management needs
to do this earn their trust but they
also learn to trust management and even
in a unionized workforce you can build a
relationship with the unionized
workforce where the workforce thinks of
themselves as employees of the
enterprise first and union members
second if you have it flipped where it's
Union first enterprise second that's
that's a path to ruin
and you can build that culture where
people enjoy coming to work they trust
each other they trust management they're
proud of what they do and they deliver
tremendous service as a result I'm sure
many of you have worked over the years
for
various enterprises and if you think of
places you work where you're really
proud to work there where you were proud
of the product proud of the of the brand
um you'll do a better job there's an old
saying in the airline business you know
how much faster you can fix an airplane
if you want to write and it's true and
you can you can get so much more out of
people if they if they're proud of where
they're working and they see the future
and they're rewarded for it and it can
be any a number of things that yet
united we have perfect attendance
programs by work group if people have
six months of perfect attendance we put
their name in a revolving drum and we
and we pull out every six months we pull
out a name from that work group and the
winner gets a brand new car with all the
taxes paid and the gross upon the taxes
and everything else they actually get a
new car we have one time bonus program
where if our aircraft are 80 percent or
more on time despite what mr. Parker
said we are in on time airline
domestically or internationally we or
both we pay we pay a bonus for that we
you know we have we have for profit
sharing programs so so when we make a
profit when when our co-workers work
together and deliver the profit we share
the profit that's what makes a great
workplace and that's what ultimately
makes makes a great company so I would
encourage all of you in your future in
your leadership positions as well really
I've had a lot of people ask me this all
time you know because I've had a really
checkered career I mean I've done a lot
of different things in my life and I
never thought I'd be in the airline
business and I sure as I didn't think
I'd be running the world's largest
airline well what I've told people is
follow your passion don't go into
Investment Banking because that's cool
and everybody's doing it and don't go
into consulting because it's cool and
everybody's doing it go follow what you
want to do if you've got a passion for
Investment Banking go for it
you've got a passion for consulting go
for it if you've got a passion for
working in the high-tech sector go for
it but go for your passion because money
is important there's no question about
it but beyond a certain amount what
matters is really enjoying coming to
work and being proud of what you do and
and and believing in the company and
believing in the future that
company and I'll tell you I've had jobs
where I was unhappy and it's a lot more
fun being in a job where you really
enjoy what you're doing and you enjoy
the people you work with and you're
proud of what you're doing and you want
to continue to improve the business it's
more person accessor so follow your
passion ignore the herd and be yourself
you know a lot of people think of you
know business people being sort of stuff
suits but the reality is is the best
thing you can do in the way you can
advance your own career and then where
you can be most attitude to simply be
yourself I like to joke if you're an
obnoxious liar then probably you're not
gonna make it in business that's not
that that kind of be yourself
but but follow your passion and be
yourself and and I think certainly with
the background Stanford Business School
you'll be incredibly successful so I'm
gonna stop right there and start and and
start taking questions but I want to end
by thanking you very much I'm honored to
come here I'm certainly honored to to be
in this spectacular look at that people
way in the back hi there
in this in this spectacular auditorium
at the beginning of this a brand new
night Business School and I want to
thank professor Parker for and for
divided me thanks a lot